[Music]
hello everyone my name is Thomas avianna
as you said I'm a data engineer at
gitlab and today we're gonna talk about
scaling processes instead of just hiring
more people I think this is very topical
especially for a lot of people that work
at smaller companies because it's it's
really easy to say we're hitting
bottlenecks we need to hire more people
and it's a lot harder to say we're
hitting bottlenecks is it because we're
not doing things as well as we could and
so that's we're gonna focus on today a
little bit about myself
I got a Poli Sci degree from the
University of Texas at Dallas the focus
in Chinese politics after that I worked
as a business intelligence engineer
before ending up at order my gear which
is a small dallas start-up there I was
responsible for green fielding a data
infrastructure on air flow and
kubernetes and that's kind of where I
got my real start as a data engineer and
now I'm a git lab helping to iterate our
data infrastructure into something more
mature more stable so that we can start
to do things like data science so real
quick this is our team only three people
top left is myself top writers are
amazing analysts Emily she saves me all
the time
and on the bottom is our manager Taylor
who does a a mix of analytics and
engineering tasks just kind of as they
come up so here's a quick rundown of
what we're gonna be going over today
first I'm gonna give you a quick rundown
on who we are get lab and what we do
it's important to have a little
background on gitlab because some of our
core values have really shaped some of
the solutions that we've come up with
next I'm going to talk about our merge
request first workflow this is kind of
the foundation of how we work it get lab
and how we get things done very
efficiently next I'm gonna talk about
our infinite data warehouses and I know
this sounds like a misleading title but
I promise you it is relatively accurate
and then finally we're gonna talk about
scaling knowledge and this is something
that's extremely important process wise
for being able to make your data team
more scalable so that every time someone
has a question about data they don't
have to come find an analyst and
spend that analyst time asking questions
hey what does this data mean how did you
get to this calculation we need to scale
that knowledge in a way that's very
self-serving doesn't take an analyst
time so get lab is billed as a product
for the entire DevOps lifecycle it takes
the approach that it's better to have a
single application based on convention
instead of configuration the get lab
model is the opposite of most current
stacks so I'm sure many of you familiar
with where it's just a handful of
disparate pieces that you kind of
engineer together in a way that usually
works and yes get lab is a code
repository but more than that it's an
entire application for collaboration so
for those that are unaware we compete in
nine different verticals currently from
managing and planning and creating so
that would be things like Trello all the
way to monitoring security but it's
impossible to talk about gitlab the
product but also bringing up gitlab the
company we're 100% distributed and
believed in being as open and
transparent as humanly possible for
instance our entire analytics repo is
completely open-source and even
accepting contributions just a few weeks
ago I got an issue assigned to me around
riding some sequel for date calculations
and someone actually hopped in and just
wrote it for me that was amazing our
employee handbook is also completely
open and online with over 1,400 pages I
believe we have someone on staff
full-time that just writes things for
our handbook so it's it's growing at a
very quick pace so while there are a
number of values that we hold dear
gitlab iteration is one of my favorites
iteration is what allows us to move and
adapt so quickly this value is having a
huge key for us in getting our data team
to where we are now despite our
relatively limited resources you'll see
this theme come up a few times as we go
through the talk and before we get into
the merge requests here's a quick aside
that I'd like everyone just to keep in
the back of their minds for the rest of
the talk and maybe even take back with
them when they go back to work it's the
idea of incidental complexity
I was first introduced to this idea of
incidental complexity by a paper about
software design called out of the tar
pit by Ben mosey and Peter Marx it is
kind of long but I do suggest reading if
you're interested in these things it's
very very eye-opening
it describes the primary problem with
developing software and I think also
applies to the processes that we create
which is that over time the complexity
of an application grows exponentially
things get harder to maintain harder to
extend and harder to reason about this
is a trap the foundational idea is this
your solutions should not be more
complicated than the problem it is
trying to solve it sounds simple on its
face but if you really get to thinking
about it have some some truly profound
consequences engineers tend to write
software that overcomplicate solutions
relative to their problems it's also
goes true for processes that we create
this concept of incidental complexity
has really stuck with me and always
assist me in making better decisions
when I reframe them in which of these
solutions leads to Lex less complexity
so our first topic is about murdered
requests these are the backbone of our
workflow and we've adapted the
traditional CI CD workflow to cater to
our needs as a data team although
ironically the first slide and merge
request is actually about issues
everything starts with an issue whether
it's a discussion a bug report a
refactor suggestion or anything else
that might come up it has to have an
issue issues are a single source of
truth for what we are thinking about and
working on as a team if it's not in an
issue it's safe to assume that it
doesn't exist and no one's thinking
about it this stuff is pretty standard
and stuff like get lab or even github or
Trello or things like that but it's very
important to be strict about it
so if issues are the idea what about the
execution of those ideas that's where a
merge request come in a merge quest also
known as a pull request and other
version control software I won't name
there the smallest unit of change that
we have anytime we want to make a change
to our data warehouse our day
structure any part of our pipelines has
to go through a merge request we create
merge requests directly from issues so
that they're automatically tied to
sharing the same attributes be it
milestone wait due date who's assigned
to it well I would assume everyone with
an engineering background will be
familiar with version controlling and
merge requests I've anecdotally found it
much less common to get entire data team
buy-in on version control and that
includes data analysts and data
scientists sometimes there are excuses
such as maybe the tools we use don't
support version control or my least
favorite excuse is that it's too
technical for analysts or maybe they
just in general don't see the benefit of
keeping everything version controlled so
besides the general advantage of version
control why make such a big deal around
merge requests it's this right here this
is what a CI CD pipeline looks for one
of our merge requests the key for us is
that for every merge request we have an
entire review instance of our data
warehouse and a CI CD pipeline this
gives us the ability to run full
pipelines from end to end all in a
sandbox so if I make a one-line change
to a model I can run extractors I can
load it I can run tests I can do
everything I need to to make sure that
when I push that change into production
nothing is going to break this saves you
a lot of time the implications here are
huge in relation to testability
reproducibility and understanding the
history of your data this is all great
but how do we get to this underlying
infrastructure this brings us to our
next topic infinite data warehouses well
it is a bit hyperbolic our underlying
infrastructure allows us to be able to
spin up a practically infinite number of
data warehouses so as a paradigm shift
for us in terms of testability and data
integrity so let's get started
here's a meme because I was told they
were required to give us talk so I
obliged it's Oprah giving everyone data
warehouses so in many cases and
admittedly this is just an Akita you're
welcome
the infrastructures don't have the same
rigorous level of testing and quality
checks is something like web
applications tend to write the testing
infrastructure for web applications the
normal software is extremely robust
they've been perfecting it for what 10
15 20 years at this point
it's very mature and believe it or not
as I'm sure some managers would like to
believe the reason that data
infrastructures aren't tested as
thoroughly is not just because data
engineers are lazy or incompetent
testing data infrastructures as
rigorously as something like a web
application is usually orders of
magnitude more difficult from the huge
quantities of data to the heavy reliance
on third-party data sources there's a
lot of stuff that we just don't control
or have a hard time testing using common
patterns so that brings us to this
concept of infinite data warehouses how
are we able to adapt our C C ICD
pipelines to such a different tech stack
so we came up with two initial solutions
to decide between right so first we can
clone the entire data warehouse for each
branch physically clone the entire data
warehouse as well my guess it's not very
scalable as you start to get into the
terabytes of data takes longer not a
great solution but as we talked about
iteration before it's okay as a
short-term solution if you have a
relatively small amount of data and it's
not overly complicated this might be a
feasible solution in the short term but
then we also found out it's potentially
very expensive we personally were on
Google cloud sequel using Postgres and
as you can imagine the more merge
requests you have open the more data
warehouses you have split up it gets
quite expensive solution number two and
this is a solution I've heard proposed
more often it's to generate a data
warehouse that is is a statistically
representative
sample of your real data warehouse so
benefits extremely scalable right you
probably have parameters you can say how
much data you want all those kinds of
things but the problems are that it adds
complexity right and we want to minimize
the complexity that we add and
furthermore even though it might not be
as expensive in terms of infrastructure
it's expensive and engineering time
right you have to have an engineer come
up with solution after you maintain that
solution they have to test it all things
that add complexity and cost so what did
we choose initially well initially we
chose to go with the first iteration our
first solution here which was ok is a
short-term solution let's just clone our
actual data warehouse physically for
every single merge request and see how
far we can get however as we grew we
started to hit the hard limits on
scalability both for Postgres and for
this workflow in general the times have
spin up those new instances took longer
it got more and more expensive and we
knew that we needed our second iteration
so if this was our skateboard we need a
scooter for our second iteration we
found something that gave us what we
think is the best of both worlds and
then some I'm sure many of you have
heard of snowflake it's not the newest
thing in the world and I've spoken to
plenty of people here they're already on
it but we're using in a way that seems a
little bit unique
so snowflake decouples compute from
storage was as a concept really liked
and it's stored in a proprietary format
and cloud storage AWS for AWS for us for
example and we can scale up or scale
down our compute power by choosing
larger or smaller clusters independent
of the amount of data we're storing so
what were some of the driving factors
behind our decision to move to snowflake
one as I just mentioned you might
imagine being a cloud-based data
warehouse it's extremely scalable the
key point here though is the second one
which is that it has a robust metadata
store and the implications of that are
very important the first implication of
having a robust better data store is
something called zero copy cloning so
you get near instantaneous
replication of almost any database
object to be at a table a schema or even
an entire database it seems crazy right
and there's no extra charge for
duplicated data so how does it do this
I think the easiest way to explain it is
to think of it in terms of get right so
we've got a branch of the data warehouse
but just like when you're using git it
doesn't actually make a second copy of
all the code that isn't changed right
still there all it has to do is keep
track of the diff
that's exactly how snowflake does it and
next and I think this is probably going
to be interesting to a lot of the data
scientists in the room is you have the
ability to merge changes back into the
original object so say your data
scientists you have a say table a
creative name and it maybe have some
static training data in it but you're
not happy with it right you want to add
some or features maybe normalize some of
it but you also don't want to change it
in place in case you mess something up
so what you can do is you can make a
copy of table A to B table B another
creative name and you can make all the
changes you want in table B and when it
gets to the way you like it you can just
merge it back into table a and it'll
update table a just as if you were
merging a git branch so this is awesome
and it's this feature of zero copy
cloning that allows us to have a full
data warehouse for every single merge
request so the moment you hit that merge
request button that create merge request
button we have a script that goes out
and creates a zero copy clone which
takes a minute or so sometimes less and
then anything you run in that pipeline
will automatically get pointed at that
database so there's no extra work on the
part of the user it's all handled by our
CI CD pipeline they just do everything
like normal the second thing we have
here is time travel so the state of the
database has kept her up to 90 days and
this is going to depend on your demos
snowflake but one of the things we love
about it which fits in with our mantra
of data testing and integrity is that
you can run a query against
say to the database right now and then
run a query against the state of the
database a week ago and compare the
difference right so you can guarantee
that if any of your major metrics or any
of your summary statistics start to get
off you'll be in you'll be alerted about
it right that's pretty fantastic and the
only thing you have to do to make that
work is just put an app and then the
time stamp that you want to run that
query yet next and I'm gonna throw web
developers under the bus here hopefully
we don't have any in here say a web
developer somehow gets into your data
warehouse who knows what they're doing
and they maybe make some changes that
you don't like maybe they accidentally
mess up some production data who knows
it's a web developer they're capable of
anything you can actually roll back to
previous versions of your data warehouse
and it could be specific objects AVMs up
a specific table you can roll back to an
earlier version of that table and erase
anything they might have done and in
line with that if they even go so far as
to drop something you can unwrap it
which i think is pretty fantastic if
you've ever worked with web developers
you know exact what I'm talking about so
having an infant a data warehouse is one
piece of adapting our CSV pipelines and
that really helps us streamline our
process around making changes to our
code base because you can go in if it's
something as small as one line change
make the one line change start up the
pipeline and just click a button that
says merge when successful so that way
you can make that change move on with
your life you know it'll be in the
codebase of all those pipelines run if
something fails it'll alert you it won't
merge and you can go fix it right that's
much much cheaper than making that one
line change
assuming you're probably not gonna break
anything breaking something spending
five hours to figure out what you broke
from that one line change that shouldn't
have broken anything and now you're back
to square one so all that's fantastic
but the modeling and transformation
steps are just as important for being
able to test these changes before they
go live along with that is the rarely
talked about documentation step where
data is documented after it is modeled
and transformed
so what is the date of Tina's priority
I've been thinking about this a lot and
I try to distill it down into the
simplest thing I could the number one
job of a data team is just to increase
the amount of factual knowledge that an
organization has available we've gotten
really good especially I can say from
the engineering side we've gotten really
good at creating pipelines moving data
around transforming modeling gotten
really good at that part but I think the
part that we as an industry still lack
in is documentation how do we
disseminate that knowledge to the rescue
organization and I think a lot of people
would just say oh it's visualization
right I make a make a graph and all of a
sudden all the knowledge that I have
about this data is is given to the
person looks at the graph that's not
really how it works that's one piece of
the puzzle but good documentation is the
other and here now I'm coining a new
buzzword you're all welcome to use this
and I know yesterday we had ETTL so we
can meet in the middle and we'll be ET
TLD we're gonna have extract load
transform and document right
documentation should be a first-class
citizen as long as your data team has a
better understanding of your data than
the organization at large the Devi theme
becomes a de facto knowledge bottleneck
so we have a three person data team
acute lab we have almost 150 total
employees and we're doing our best to be
a data-driven organization that means
that if we don't have documentation
every single minute someone would be
coming to us saying hey I just looked at
these slides I'm not really sure what
these numbers mean can you explain to me
how you came to those conclusions right
we would get nothing done or at least
Emily wouldn't get anything done because
she'd be constantly answering those
questions and like I said earlier
visualization can only get you so far
because the meaning of the underlying
data in a chart might still be
completely unknown to the user
yes revenues revenue but all companies
might calculate that differently it's
really important to keep this in mind so
unless your data team is writing
documentation around their knowledge of
your data in fact
they aren't doing their part to help
scale knowledge but luckily for us and
luckily for you there is a tool that
helped us with this it's DBT which was
mentioned in the talk before this and I
think introduced very well but also does
a little bit more than what was talked
about so it's an open source
transformation layer and for us that is
the single source of truth for any and
all transformations that are applied to
our data between the raw tables and what
gets visualized but there are two other
key areas of DBT that I think get
shortchanged sometimes one of them being
testing DBT has data quality and
integrity checks built in in the form of
DBT tests there are two kinds of tests
in DBT you have schema tests which test
pretty mundane and things like
uniqueness not null that are things like
that but then you also have custom tests
which just asserts that if a query
returns zero rows it's considered
passing and you can imagine how with
that much flexibility you can write some
very interesting tests and between those
two testing methods DBT can help you
make huge guarantees about the quality
and integrity of your data but there's a
third feature here there really makes
DBT a must-have tool for helping to
solve this problem of knowledge
scalability and that is DBT Docs
DBT Doc's are written in markdown and
exists in the same folder as the models
that they document this colocation of
models in their documentation is
intuitive and lowers the complexity of
writing or updating documentation when
models are changed or created on each
model documentation page we can see the
details of model which is that wall of
text my boss wrote over there as well as
column level descriptions so we can see
data type of a column maybe any schema
tests we have on those columns well
guarantees we have around that and call
them oval descriptions if there are any
and then and I think this is really
interesting from an analyst point of
view or anyone that's a little more
technically inclined is the right side
is just scroll down a little bit on this
page and you can actually see the
that generates that model along with the
documentation in both of its forms I
should know because dbg compiles sequel
the you use macros in you can see either
the raw or the compiled sequel that the
database is actually seeing this is huge
this means that whenever you go in to
make a change you you can update that
model you update the documentation and
then DBT will run those models in your
CI CD pipeline
it'll make sure the documentation is
up-to-date and then it also tests you
didn't break anything as far as the
models or the integrity of the data goes
this really speeds up the process of
both creating new models and updating
models as well as scaling that knowledge
to the rest of your organization because
you can do all three of these things in
one place and I do believe that tests
are a form of documentation so that fits
an even better so here's one of our
lineage rafts from bird's eye view on
the left and then a drill down
perspective on the right so because DBT
is a transformation layer it understands
how how all of your models fit together
right so some people would say this is a
dag they call it a lineage graph same
difference it makes it trivial to
understand when a change will affect
something downstream or if you want to
make a downstream change where you need
to go upstream and this whole UI that
you've seen is completely built into DBT
simple command
DBT Docs it spins up a web server and
serves all of this to you
so models testing and documentation by
having these three key features wrapped
into one open source tool DBT has become
the foundation that we use with which to
scale our knowledge it is a single
source of truth for all three of these
things so now that you've seen where we
are what's next for the data team at
gate lab looking at the hierarchy of
data needs we are just now starting to
get into the learn and optimize phase
well this means maybe we are behind the
curve in terms of data science among
operable organizations the confidence we
have in our engineering our analytics
and our ability to scale knowledge will
allow us to iterate in the data science
space with more confidence one of our
key focuses as we go forward into this
amazing land of data science is to hold
close to our mantra of the merge request
first workflow and focus on scaling
knowledge we think this is especially
important
seeing how opaque data science can be at
times especially to people that aren't
data scientists so here are my three key
takeaways one to the best of your
ability
get everything in version control and do
everything in emerg requests this has
been a best practice in the software
industry for I don't know how long and I
think it's time the data teams really
take this to heart yes even the analysts
and even the data scientists - whether
by using some of the solutions that I
proposed or maybe coming up with your
own figure out a way to get real
production data available to test before
you merge things back into production
this will save you a lot of headaches
and this is again something that we've
seen in the software engineering
industry for a long time but we've been
slow to adapt because it's not quite a
one-to-one solution and then finally
adopt the dissemination of knowledge as
the touchstone of your data team DataViz
is only a small part of this make a
commitment to the documentation your
organization will thank you for it Thank
You Evelyn for your time
[Applause]
there's
and these are
yeah so actually the way that we have
our CI CD pipelines built is that it's
the entire database so if we run an
extract job on that on that CI CD
pipeline it'll actually pipe that data
into that copy database it won't pipe it
under production so so anything it's
really it's it's the same as far as the
code things anything you're doing is
exactly what's happening on production
it's just happening all in that in that
sandbox just
you know luckily we've yet to truncate
anything so I stood by that
time goes do we start
yeah that's a very good question we try
to solve these things with with slack
bots so the first place we found it most
effective was people asking for looker
credentials so we created a bot for that
and found that very effective so we
still point people to the docks as much
as possible we haven't taken it so far
as to have a bot that just says go look
at the DBT docks and ever they ask a
question but we're we're definitely
getting there and as DBT docks is a
relatively new feature came out in 0.11
dotto which was a few months ago at this
point so we're still working on getting
all of our documentation moved into DBT
Docs but I think once that's the
solution that will definitely definitely
be what we encourage and a lot of the
people that use the data the most
already so people in like the finance
and operations side they are savvy
enough and you know because they're in
the same organization we talk to them
enough they've already started to
understand hey I should probably just go
check
DBT Docs whereas maybe someone and like
the HR part of the organization isn't as
familiar with it hasn't had to ask a
question before and they still maybe
don't know that it exists but it's
something we're trying to get the word
out on
[Music]